spring is here and we can start
returning to some of the things we miss
like celebrations with friends and loved
ones
and that makes now the perfect time to
start your spring cleaning with zerorez
ben mckee one of the owners and of
zerorez
joins me now ben zerorez you truly are
the experts when it comes to spring
cleaning but
you're also all about helping those of
us that suffer
from allergies how do you do that
well real simple we come in and we get
your filter
your largest filter in your home cleaned
up and
that's your carpet we're able to clean
that floor without any soaps or harsh
chemicals
so that you're left with the floor that
stays cleaner longer
yes it's really a great system and it's
just
water so you don't have to worry about
any of those harsh chemicals in your
house
let's talk about your pets because
you're also the pet experts and there's
no stain that zero res is afraid of when
it comes to pet messes
there could be challenges out there but
at zebra brezz we've been around for
16 years here in las vegas we have
found an arsenal of products that safely
and effectively go after odors and
stains that are
left behind by our fur babies and we're
experts in getting those cleaned up so
that you can
have a home or a business that's fresh
and clean now i know that a lot of us
are getting back to normal but we're
still taking precautions and when zero
rest comes to your house you guys are
still taking those precautions right
absolutely we're still screwing our
employees even our customers
make sure that we're minimizing any
chances of cross-contamination we're
wearing shoe covers
face masks gloves the whole nine yards
it really is
so i've i recently had you at my house
and you cleaned up some big messes there
but it's not just carpet that you work
on
what other services do you offer
we do everything we can come in we can
clean upholstery
tile and grout wood floors draperies
even commercial carpet our our process
is amazing in a commercial setting
whether you have a hotel
casino office space we've got you
covered and you
are clearly the best in town winning
best of las vegas for two years in a row
you have a platinum rating from the
carpet and rug institute
and a big part of that is the how you
take care of
your customers and you have a great deal
going on right now
tell us what that is we do right now you
get three rooms of carpet cleaning
pre-treated cleaned
and zebra resified for only 99
and for a limited time we're gonna throw
in two free passes
to go check out cowabunga bay and have
some fun
that is perfect thank you so much ben
definitely call
zerorez and like he said get three rooms
of carpet cleaned
only 99 plus two free
passes to cowabunga bay if you want to
make an appointment all you got to do is
call at 702
840 33 or you can visit them online at
xerorezlas vegas.com
minimums and some restrictions apply